did you guys know that Colin Kaepernick
you know Colin Kaepernick he was the
football quarterback NFL didn't want to
stand for the anthem kind of became
washed up and then teams didn't want
teams didn't want to have him not
necessarily because he was totally
washed up but no one wants to deal with
the headache of of having that in the
locker room all the time but he could
stand or he could sit and fans could
stand or sit or salute the flag or not
everyone no one's Free Speech was
infringed on this is really interesting
did you know that he was actually he's
black okay nobody cares except for him
and the woksters but did you know that
he was actually adopted by white parents
that's sort of an interesting piece of
the puzzle seeing as he seems to hate
white people and whatever he defines as
white culture and all that well now he's
turning on his parents because his white
parents who adopted him a black boy Were
Somehow perpetuating racism against him
lordy lordy play the video
who's spreading a message of empowerment
in his new graphic novel change the game
written with author and University of
Chicago Professor Eve L Ewing it's his
true High School coming-of-age Story his
journey embracing his Blackness despite
resistance from many including his white
adoptive parents I know my parents love
me but they were still very problematic
things that
I went through teenage Kaepernick wanted
cornrows to match he's getting what
roles his mom asked oh your hair is not
professional oh you look like a little
Thug
you're become I said that too yeah my
God someone's mother encouraged them to
dress a certain way or have a certain
haircut that is so racist
that's what parenting is like you want
your kid to go out there and look as
good and professional and as adult and
functional as possible to maybe get a
job or do better in schools but no they
adopted a young black boy that doesn't
prove their non-racism they are still
racist
[Music]
thank you